[Music]
Warner Bross dropped a trailer of the
second Mech movie and boy oh boy do we
have a couple of topics to discuss on
that so firstly here in this video we
will discuss about the size estimation
of the Megalodon in the second movie how
many were there how big were all of them
and there sizes in comparison to the
first one and other SE monsters from
movies including Kaiju so let's get to
but it was itself consumed by a truly
gigantic Megalodon Shar which although
shouldn't be present at that time on
Earth it so going what we have seen in
the initial scenes of them diving
underwater to the trench we can clearly
see three of them in one part swimming
and circling around they are all of
different sizes a smaller one a
mediumsized Shar and the Apex speci
specimen and judging by what the
characters said that it was the biggest
me that anyone has ever seen confirms
that the largest of the three was even
larger than the shock seen in the first
movie then by inferring that this one
was the size of the shock that killed
the T-Rex we can come to a close
estimate of it by assessing the size of
the prehistoric one and with it as a
reference point we can assess the other
two as well the T-Rex in the trailer at
least its size for all intents and
purposes will be assumed as being one of
the largest individuals of its species
referring to the biggest discovered
fossilized specimen which is named
Scotty I would say that the T-Rex was
probably around 13 M or 43 ft long that
would make the Megalodon multiple times
longer and even more so in mass and
volume so in the scene will be around
four times the size of the T-Rex at
least just the length so 4 * 13 M that
is 52 M or 170 ft in length that that
was the prehistoric specimen just to be
clear but yeah the one in the modern
times would also be of a similar size
because why show a gigantic creature in
the start of the movie as a prologue and
not follow up later on with a similar
size individual to be honest I think the
T-Rex has been shed on too many times by
movies especially by the Jurassic
franchise and the scene of this trailer
the prologue also resembles a mososaurus
eating the indominous Rex in Jurassic
world it was would have been better if
the spinosaurus was the one that was
eaten alive since the Spiner is also a
semi aquatic carnivore and the largest
land predator anyway putting aside my
useless ranting we can guesstimate that
the me sizes would be as follows the
smallest around 60 ft or 18 M the middle
one as big as the second Mech from the
first movie so around 30 m or 100 ft
long and yeah the biggest would be
around 170 to 180 ft or 52 to 55 m in
length so in comparison with with the
two Megs seen in the first movie we have
the smallest of the three from this
sequel being around the same size or a
bit larger than the first Meg that was
caught and killed in the first movie the
second one in this sequel would be
around the same size and maybe even bit
bigger than the main Megalodon from the
first movie lastly the third Meg is
truly gigantic in size being around
twice as long as the big one from the
2018 flick therefore it would be squared
in amount of mass and volume
this one and the prehistoric individual
can be officially classified as small
scale guu therefore belonging to a list
of the largest underwater monsters at
least underwater movie Monsters of all
time therefore I would say that this
Megalodon although gigantic is still in
the middle rankings in the top largest
underwater movie creatures and still a
small scale Kaiju so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
and most of all smash that Bell IC on
for regular updates and new videos here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam